(upbeat music)
- Hey, I see you here week
after week, but you never sing.
- Me?
No, I couldn't.
I'm not some pop
star super singer.
I'm just me.
Well, maybe that's what
the world needs to see.
You know, it takes a hero
to express themselves.
- I don't know.
- Go on, all right,
you might be surprised.
Here, take this.
A little courage.
(gentle music)
(gentle piano music)
- This is for you,
Dad, wherever you are.
♪ I love the police
because they keep me safe ♪
♪ We must respect them
because my dad is one ♪
♪ Yes, my dad is the police
and he is noble and brave ♪
♪ And if my grades
are good enough ♪
♪ He lets me drive his truck ♪
♪ All lives matter,
especially my dad ♪
♪ Donald Trump is my king ♪
♪ I want to taste
his sweet flesh ♪
♪ Build the wall,
build the wall ♪
♪ Build the wall, oh,
build the wall, oh ♪
♪ I am 11 years old ♪
(crowd groans)
♪ I am 11 (yelps) ♪
♪ I am 11 ♪
- Well, I should've
given her that shit beer.